a man is and one of the tops in the
business at evaluating National Football
League talent and also seeing a lot of
these guys in person while part of
ESPN's college football coverage he is
Tom McShea back here on the Rich Eisen
show from the worldwide leader in sports
how are you sir I'm great rich how are
you oh I gotta tell ya I'm not pleased
Todd I'm not pleased I just saw chef
what's up I mean I just saw chef door
say chase Young's not gonna participate
in on-field drills are we get in there
we're to the point where the top
defensive prospect is gonna treat the
combines on-field drills like like a
quarterback is that what we got now
what's going on I'm sure we're inching
towards it you know and I'm sure there
are a lot of crusty old Scouts that are
that are angry and not and it's
frustrating but but it is what it is and
and you gotta you gotta adjust I mean
usually the defensive guys all show up
and participate right yeah I mean
usually it's the quarterbacks and you
know a receiver who's got a little
strain in his calf here and there but
usually the rest of the guys come on
come and work out and compete you know
he didn't play that well down the
stretch his final three games weren't
that great and I finished up his tape
and I loved him physically and I you
know you over the last five years of
Edge rushers and his great is is right
up there with with all the other cop
guys I mean I've got a 95 grade on on
chase young I got had a 95 on Bosa Nick
bozo Joey Bosa miles Garrett and then a
94 on on Brad that shot coming out of NC
State so those are the top five edge
rushers in my opinion in the last five
years he certainly is up there but the
BOCES worked out even though you know
nick Ranna what was it for he ran in the
four sevens I want to say that Joey ran
up for eight for eight two and they were
both really disappointed by it
miles Garrett had had a great workout
but you know it doesn't matter just show
up and compete I guess is my whole point
and so yeah there's some frustration
there it doesn't look like Joe burrow is
gonna throw from what I understand but
we'll we'll see what what happens there
and obviously to we're talking about
Aloha can't do anything because the hip
injury and he'll still be one of the you
know one of the the biggest focuses of
the entire combine coverage and
sure and what he's doing and where he's
eating and who he's meeting with how
people are responding to him and and the
leadership he's showing on the field and
this that and the other thing but you
know it it's frustrating to see a guy
like chase who who still have some
things to prove deciding not to not to
work out well I guess the point is is
that he's either gonna be number one
overall because Joe Barrow is gonna
force his way out of Cincinnati
I mean since in Cincinnati's United
States heck with it we'll go with the
surefire kid from the Ohio State or it's
gonna be number two because Joe burrow
is going to either Cincinnati whoever
trades up to Cincinnati to go get him so
I guess he's just like I'm number one
I'm number two what do I got to do this
I'll work out at Columbus and and
whatnot even though that gives off the
impression that he doesn't want to
compete and and I guess that's that
that's his prerogative so let's take
this one at a time starting with borough
he's got nine inch hands Todd what do we
make of this funny it's not funny I
actually I put some stock into the hands
man okay what is funny to me is is that
Jake from had eight and seven eighths of
an inch hand span you know we're
measuring from the end of your pinkie to
the end of your thumb and then you've
got nine inches for Joe borough and for
some reason we're gonna look at those
numbers and Scouts are going to look at
those numbers and say all eight seven
eight once when you get in eighth
category you i've legitimately gone back
a twenty-year 17-year study those of
combine results as i have 17 years study
there's not a single quarterback who had
eight anywhere in the eight inch you
know eight inch range for hand span that
has had sustained success in the NFL but
nine inch you know there there are some
guys right right at nine inches so it
it's it's one of those things that's
it's kind of the Mendoza line it's a red
flag number whatever you want to say Joe
burrow nine inches there there are some
guys that have had success it is a
little bit of concern in terms of ball
control but you watch you watch him play
and and it was never really an issue you
know I mean he
there isn't anything that jumps out on
tape in terms of throwing in the rain or
protecting the football that really
concerns you or jumps out when you when
you evaluate him so you have to kind of
you have to look at both sides you have
to evaluate the tape versus the number
but that 8 and 7/8 inches is different
from nine inches whether you like it or
not and it's a ridiculous thing to say
cuz it's 1/8 of an inch well 9 is also
the number of bells that he will be at
which he will be sitting down on Tuesday
in the morning at a podium and meeting
with the medium for the first time 9
a.m. and on Tuesday and I imagine it's
just gonna be put to him point-blank is
there an issue between you and the
Bengals do you want to go play for him
any any form or format of what gives
from the media to Joe borough are you
what do you what are you hearing amongst
your evaluators Scouts and your contacts
is there any smoke is there a fire what
do we got here on the borough and
Bengals front Todd you know I'm I'm
actually really close with with Jordan
Paula and he's training with Jordan
Palmer yep and obviously Carson has said
what Carson Palmer has said what he said
I to be completely honest with you I
haven't asked Jordan yet because I hate
asking blunt questions like that to put
people on the spot but I'm gonna have to
ask him when I when I see him on Tuesday
tomorrow and just see what he says
because it's it's becoming such a
situation and everyone on the league is
kind of talking about it and it's it's
all rumors you know and any question
that he's answered if you really go look
at the context it's because he's been
asked that and he comes out he's a
different cat if you meet with him I've
met with him yeah a couple times 30
minutes at a time and he's a little bit
of a different cat and that he doesn't
care what you think and I remember like
Brian Griese and I have done games for
the last few years and we we walk out of
meetings especially with quarterbacks
and Brian's is intelligent as anyone
I've ever been around
in terms of evaluating quarterbacks and
just knowing the position and every time
we walk out we usually I would say 9 out
of 10 times usually will say out that
guy was impressive and like yeah and
vice versa or
I'm not so sure with with Joe we walk
out the room and I what do you think
he's like I don't know what to think
I don't either you know and then you get
to know him a little bit more and it's
just that he he's so confident in
himself and he kind of attacks the
quarterback position like a linebacker
because his brother play linebacker his
dad's a 20 plus year coach his other
brother played safety in both of
Nebraska I mean he's just kind of a
tough guy playing the quarterback
position and so everything about his
personality tells me that he's not the
type of guy that's going to say no or
try to pull an Eli Manning and force a
trade and those sorts of things but the
fact that he spent all this time with
with Jordan Palmer and and around Carson
Palmer a little bit and and knowing that
he wants to compete and win you know you
it makes me concern that there there
could be something there now I know and
then the connection of TJ Houshmandzadeh
is working with him as well he has given
more voice to the you know be careful by
going to the Bengals front
I mean I'm paraphrasing and then and
then just his comment where he said that
he had leverage at one point and again I
might be taking completely out of
context but he did drop that l word and
the question is is like look you don't
have leverage in terms of how long your
contract is or what you're paid your
slotted so what is the leverage and what
leverage do you have unless you what
let's put it this way what leverage is
there to exact unless you intend not to
go right so that's I mean that's the
only members and and in trying to force
and maybe trying to force Cincinnati to
and when free agency starts very soon
force them or at least put pressure on
them to go out and get some players and
and try to get some wide receivers and
try to get a better supporting cast
around them although you know they've
got talent if everyone's back healthy
for the the Bengals they've got talent
yeah and the offensive side of the ball
so you know I the leverage thing was the
only one that that was interesting
because it is a trigger word and what is
the leverage the lever
I'm gonna try to force a trade but the
problem if you're Cincinnati who are you
going to trade with if you move to five
and and you know this there's a proposed
deal you move to five with the dolphins
and get a bunch of picks you could all
of a sudden you know wake up and and
burros gone to is gone
and now you better love Justin Herbert
and I don't see Justin Herbert from
Oregon as a top ten pick in my opinion
you don't you probably will go in the
top ten I just don't see that I don't
see that on tape I see inconsistency I
think there's potential there I think he
can develop I think Jordan love from
Utah State has a lot of potential as
well but he's even further away from
from being ready to play in the NFL my
point is there are two quarterbacks in
this draft and if you don't get one of
those two and Joe burrow into a tongue
of I Aloha then you're on the outside
looking in and and I I just don't have
any strong conviction in any of the
other quarterbacks past those two well
Tom McShea here in the Rich Eisen show
let's gain this out a little bit more
cuz the Bengals do have and I know
bangles fans may not want to hear it
it's not like the cupboards totally bare
I mean Andy Dalton is there right I mean
so you could you could technically stay
the course there there is Trevor
Lawrence next year for whatever
sweepstakes you might want to throw your
hat in that ring and also the word is
that Baro wants to go to Carolina and
now the reason why that word might be
existing is that Joe Brady's been hired
to be the offensive court over there and
Matt rule is got seven years and if
you're gonna go to a spot where you know
the owner has made a statement and he's
made a statement with his aggressiveness
and getting rule and getting Joe Brady
and giving them the contracts and you're
concerned about being in a spot where
there's a riptide of coaches and
offensive coordinators and your whole
career is gonna go down the toilet
because of all that then that's where he
wants to go how real do you think that
would be possibly Todd I mean you can't
go to Carol how do you get a trade with
Carolina going from seven all the way up
seven it would be set up and sorry seven
up to one I mean that that you're
talking about
second and third this year first next
year and probably say I mean the amount
that it would cost Carolina to go up and
go get that guy in jobber Oleg and I
know they I'm sure they love them how do
you not love them based off of one of
the best college football seasons we've
ever seen from a quarterback in the
history of the game and then knowing
that the offensive coordinator who took
him from a game manager to that this
season that we just saw a national
championship and and a Heisman Trophy is
there in Carolina like I get that but
how do you move up and what do you
what's the cost to go to go do that I
think you would have to wind up doing
like maybe a trade I don't know three
four somewhere in that range and then
like and then have the Bengals draft him
and then trade after the fact something
like that where where at least you're
not giving up all of that compensation
and then you make a deal but is it still
going to cost you a ton in order to go
get one guy and as much as I love Joel
borough I would rather move back if
you're telling me that Joe doesn't want
to play for me and that this could be an
issue well if that's the case I'm not
saying it's the case but if that's the
case I would rather move back and get a
bunch of picks and then next year being
the the running for Trevor Lawrence who
I think is better than both of these
guys then then you know then wind up
just stuck there and drafting a
quarterback who doesn't want to be in
Cincinnati who has nine-inch hands is
gonna have to play in Pittsburgh
Cincinnati in Cleveland right for the
vast majority of this year Todd McClay
here in the Rich Eisen show what are you
hearing about - oh he's got the 10-inch
hands we know that but what are you
hearing about his hip what are you
hearing and he's gonna blow away the
meetings he's gonna come out of this
combine with everybody falling head over
heels in love with him the Dolphins
might fall back in love with him based
on what your whatever reporting you
might hear or believe in well what are
you hearing about - going in Todd
it's all medical and he's a stud if you
were and I think I don't know if I said
this to you before I know I've said it
before but if you were to give me a
crystal ball and promise me 10 years of
health I would take two over Jill Barrow
even though I love Joe Burrell and I
don't think there's a big difference but
I think two is I think he's special I
think he's special from a leadership
standpoint the poise that he brings he's
today's NFL quarterback Joe is - I mean
they're both so great in the pocket they
have such a great natural feel their
instincts how quick they are with their
progression reads but to a his deep
accuracy is exceptional its unique and
his touch and timing and his ability to
just kind of maneuver within the pocket
and go from read to to read three where
most guys start to panic in their eyes
drop and they take off and run he's just
like I'm cool I'm good and he works
through it and he he almost the boss
coming out almost before you can imagine
him seeing what you see it and so that's
that's what makes him special to me so
well it's not I I know the same things
that everyone else knows he's a
phenomenal football player he would he
would arguably be the first overall pick
if he was healthy and didn't have the
hip injury and it's all going to come
down to medical we've seen progression
and it's good progress but there's so
much more to learn and the interesting
part for me rich is the game of chicken
that's going to go on between you know
the Dolphins and the medical report
because the Dolphins are the team that
are able to go five picks in the first
two rounds three in the first first
round they're the team that has the most
ammunition to move up and go get him
but how long do you wait before you go
move up or as a team by like Carolina or
you know anyone but behind them that
needs a quarterback are they going to
just pull the trigger and wind up at
number two or number three and now
you're either sitting there and saying
you know we missed out and so what do we
do with all these picks we get a bunch
of good players but we're not going to
get our quarterback I'll tell you what
Todd and then that you hit that spot on
Todd make sure you hear from from ESPN
because I asked that of Daniel Jeremiah
last week and you know I'm about to
spend an absurd amount of time with him
and a booth at the combine I'm like
thank you I said basically like if I'm
if I'm the Dolphins you got to go get
him now because you know everybody's
gonna fall in love with him
and and the price is gonna go up and to
me the report from Armando cigarro that
that the Dolphins kind of dig Justin
Herbert maybe as much if not more than
tourists sounds to me that they're there
they're trying to drive the price down
that Detroit's gonna either ask or
already has asked and his answer is like
you you can't make that trade until
you're a thousand percent sure on the
medical you can't do that you know you
can't do that and then have it all of a
sudden come up draft day oh yeah there's
been a setback with his hip you just
can't do that is what his point was
right and so you you've saved up for for
the past couple years to get here to
have these five fix you know that
everyone's whatever for two of tanking
for two of fun but the bottom line is
they put themselves in a position to go
get a guy this year and so now you're
gonna give up those picks and move up
and all of a sudden your medical staff
comes back and says you know we're not
comfortable or he's not progressing or
we think it's going to be degenerative
he's not gonna be the same player I mean
there's so many things that can come up
in the next couple of months right and
you're talking about you know not only
giving away extra picks but then making
a 30 million dollar investment in a
player of guaranteed money forget all
the other stuff but guaranteed money
thirty million dollars and expecting him
to be the face of your friendship and
franchise and beat the guy the first
quarterback you've really had in decades
and all of a sudden you're sitting there
and your medical staff is saying no so
now you got it if you make a deal to go
to three and Burroughs gone at one let's
say hypothetically and chase young goes
at two now what do we do we're gonna
move up and give it away those picks to
take harbor no absolutely not
so we're gonna take Garrett Brown a
really good defensive tackle but we we
gave away these picks and we could have
maybe gotten gotten Derek brown at five
or Jeff hakuna the cornerback from Ohio
State fiver Isaiah Simmons the safety or
the linebacker from from Clemson at five
so it just doesn't make sense but then
like if you're sitting there in musical
chairs and you're all of a sudden you're
without a seat and now Justin Herbert's
the answer I'm coming I like Justin
Herbert I think he has a lot to work
with I think he's working on becoming
more
leader but he's a self-proclaimed
introvert he's inconsistent he's never
had to carry a football team
I just Herbert is such a drop-off from
these other two quarterbacks it I don't
know it's if it is a really tough
position that Tom Garfinkel the CEO and
president Chris Greer the GM Flores the
head coach it's a really brutal
situation that they're in trying to make
this decision based off of information
that you just don't have yet last thing
for you Todd before I let you go
the answer to a question going into the
combine that you're eager to have
answered because you think the combine
can't answer it would be what what's the
one thing going in well there's 337
players right invited to the combine and
the one that I am most interested and
most excited to watch is Henry rugs the
wide receiver from Alabama can he can he
break the number I mean I we're gonna be
watching you and you're gonna be
covering it and and you know the only
thing you guys are gonna be talking
about when the wide receivers are
running is when the ARS come up and rugs
is there is he gonna break the number
because you know reportedly he can run
like a four to four to one somewhere in
that range so we'll we'll see if it
happens and I think does that change his
evaluation no he's fast he's not a great
route runner he still has the ability to
do
I wouldn't take him to top ten Jerry
Judy his teammate at Alabama CD lamb
from Oklahoma there better wide
receivers but he is going to be one of
the most intriguing players to walks in
the entire graph and Jalen rhaegar keep
an eye on him nobody knows him TCU wide
receiver he's gonna run a fast number as
well and I think it's gonna wind up
helping him that'll be Thursday night
and then I'm
well I'll see you in Indianapolis Todd I
look forward to seeing your brother
travel
right back at you that's Todd McShea at
McShea 13 for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app